[Music]
during the first golden era of space
exploration we went to the moon then we
sort of dropped the ball for 50 years
we've been basically spinning wheels
around the planet Earth however now we
have the infusion of funds from Silicon
Valley billionaires we have new energies
new strategies new plans to go back into
outer space and things have changed new
parties have entered into the game and
so I say we're entering the second
golden era of space exploration some
people are a little bit hesitant to pass
the baton to private enterprise because
of course private enterprises well for a
profit by definition not to mention the
fact that there are egos involved and
some people like to go back to the old
days of NASA the problem is space travel
is potentially very expensive especially
the way government's do space travel it
costs $10,000 to put a pound of anything
into orbit around the planet Earth just
a $10,000 to put a book going around the
planet earth in outer space that's why
we need to have an infusion of public
and private funds and that's where Elon
Musk Jeff Bezos and Google billionaires
come into the picture and of course
let's be honest about it
they're not in it to just wave the
American flag they're in it for a profit
they're in it for yo also they're in it
for a vision and that's what's different
you see back in the 1960s the vision was
beat the Russians beat the Russians that
was our vision well we did it we scored
a touchdown and we took our football and
went home now we have a new vision
first of all Elon Musk read Isaac
Asimov's foundation series as I did as a
child and was thrilled by the idea of
creating a multi-planet civilization a
civilization that spans the galaxies
because of course you have to
realize that the dinosaurs did not have
a space program that's why there are no
dinosaurs in this room right now how
could there not any dinosaurs here
because they didn't have a space program
and that's why Elon Musk wants to create
a space faring civilization and then we
have Jeff Bezos of Amazon he has a
vision too he wants to make the earth
into a garden heavy energy goes into
outer space pollution goes into outer
space while the earth is kept as a park
as a celestial garden as a jewel in the
heavens so he has a vision now NASA of
course today unfortunately has no vision
and of course you can't expect anymore
because of course they are publicly
funded they have tremendous amounts of
bureaucracy to take care of many
regulations to obey and that's why the
SLS booster rocket is already way over
budget has so many cost overruns that it
may never fly at all
[Music]